alors la chanson qui nous représente à
l'eurovision est ce que vous y croyez à
ce que vous n'y croyez pas ce qu'on
voulait mais est ce que vous n'aimez pas
en tout cas moi les artistes je trouve
formidable
est ce qu'on pensait qu'on va gagner je
vous donnais des cinq favoris des
bookmakers
et vous n'allez me donner vos favoris en
même temps alors vous vous aimez tome
vous sentez bien
c'est très joli je sais pas si c'est une
chanson qui est fait pour l'eurovision
mais elle est très très jolie après il
peut y avoir des surprises année
dernière le portugais je pense que
personne n'attendait elle était très
jolie était pas du tout eurovision
également une bonne surprise et ça a
marché sait c'est qu'ils votent favori
bout battant la russie la russie
oui alors la russie est bien jolie sont
pas dans les cinq parmi la russie je
vous le dis la russie c'est ça ouais
mais là aussi c'est très bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vocalement il se passe quelque chose est
cassé le beau et vous pensez que la
france a terminé combien puisque vous
aimez je pense aux 15e 16e
ah ouais je reste sur 23 actions man
clark ouais c'était en quart en trois en
trois ans car entre les animations
bandas
c'est pas la finale merci les
chirurgiens merci r douceur alors il ya
l'autre qui le 10 août à deauville et
missions non c'était pour ça merci à
vous garder qu'on va terminer combien
matthieu delormeau alors les bookmakers
10/10 je crois oui malheureusement un
petit peu plus loin une jolie chanson en
effet avec un joli message mais je crois
que c'est pas très heureux d'y penser
qu'on va terminer déclic est votre
favori d'israël alors donc génial israël
pour les bookmakers c'est le grand
favori avec la chanteuse n'est pas émis
n'osait y el centre à l'eurovision le
titre toy et de montre à quoi ça
ressemblait en instance est le favori de
l'eurovision en numéro en deuxième
position c'est l'estonie république
tchèque belgique
voilà qui est numéro 4 chez les
bookmakers et 5e bulgarie ch on a les
favoris des bookmakers
alors le favori 2 ben j'avais de vous
c'est que ni israël israël et bars et le
favori vous le dites si le favori
actuellement pour tout le monde puisque
c'est la chanson qui est placé numéro
une part les bookmakers
regardez
[Musique]
amano
on
[Musique]
alors que l'horizon vous moi nous israël
ultra elle aussi gilles estonie
naisseline a exactement ils sont
deuxièmes actuellement en deuxième place
chez les bookmakers des estoniens c'est
la chanteuse et li na n'est chayer va
ouais elle représentera son pays et la
france pensait qu'ils vont terminer
combien 12e si c'est truqué
sinon 40e regardez l'estonie tiens
[Musique]
les belges je comprends pourquoi vous
l'aimez bien vos maxime galy celle
israël également paul décalé et
finalement dans l'air du temps et la
france déterminer combien alors à vous
savez amiral est terminé 6e
alma 12e ont peut-être nous on va
terminer 24e d'accord 18 d'accord est
merci web est très sympa vraiment je
l'appelle il faut se méfier les
bookmakers
la dernière portugal était classée
cinquième au terme du premier tiers les
bons pronostics cette année c'était
amaury vassili le français numéro 1 des
bookmakers l'a fait vite je sais plus
combien 15e avant des mémoires et moi
quand j'ai les faits c'était patricia
kaas a été première on a terminé
huitième oui mais bon là mais souvent la
norvège mais c'est très très favorite
avait terminé loin devant aussi une
année je m'en rappelle
voilà puisque c'était s'était d'ailleurs
c'est en russie et ailleurs voilà jeune
arnaud guilhem cette année très très
bien oui merci moi c'est la macédoine
mais non j'ai pas vu le clip j'ai vu que
la chanson mais la chanson shoes en la
retient tout de suite donc la macédoine
alors ils sont pas dans les favoris
non non je ne sais pas si vous aimez
l'absence ou la salade gmail clip j'ai
vu entendu seulement et gère tout juste
retenu ah ouais d'accord et vous voulez
qu'on la voit pas j'aimerais bien
découvrir moi parce qu'en fait vous ne
bossez pas vous les bras les jambes
lourdes y a plus les crocs action pour
l'année prochaine pour nous suivre en
direct
[Applaudissements]
regardez la macédoine
[Musique]
jean guilbault délire bonjour la cedr
alors vous le dis donc les favoris bas
voulait jouer au t5 favoris ou pas
démontré donc israël 7 favori numéro 1
au numéro de république tchèque
alors c'est la république tchèque le
chanteur qui s'appelle mais colas joseph
il chantera le titre là on aime bien à
un problème bien à vous avez bien le
délire ah oui oui bah quoi tu es bon tu
peux vous dites est république tchèque
on y trouve les mots vous allez la
capitale d'air du meet shake a mis la
capitale régionale jean luc godet
l'heure exacte vous êtes déjà la prague
jamais mêlé marial est pourquoi c
[Musique]
entre israël et qu israël est prêt
public pour l'instant moi chez toi marie
pas mal merci merci d'être là merci de 2
à 6 ans 4e à seynod ami à moi je vais te
mettre à fond derrière aux labels c'est
ma quatrième ils sont souvent quatrième
[Rires]
à la chanteuse s'appelle ces mecs elle
va chanter matters of time le dire leur
la mère du toro un question question de
temps question de temps
[Musique]
non
pour la science s'est pas plaint du
vénitien qui serait aussi alors et je
m'appelle cinquième favori c'est la
bulgarie le groupe s'appelle équinoxe et
vont interpréter le titre veolia maxime
génie tout à l'heure ils étaient là ah
oui mais c'est vrai bien sûr c'est la
manière ça c'est vrai on regarde c'est
parti
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
c'est chiant à mourir menace assez
chiant à mourir 2 alors qu'elle est ma
télé on peut les faire un petit week-end
à prague alors bas à soigner fatigué
peut me rencontrer